but you do Edibles or do you do flour I
don't smoke it no oh so you just edible
just to eat it and how convenient like
but it's the thing is I also have
hemorrhoids so I've got like I've got
I've got I've got like these weed I've
got weed gummies and then I've got Fiber
Gummies just Giants of fiberglass and
I've got like a 10 year old son he's
like why can't I have a gummy only
they're adult food yeah yeah Jim do they
bother you so much and would you get a
hemorrhoid duct to me why can't you just
get them removed I've had a surgery I
know that's super painful that one was
that was seven years ago that was the
worst it's a varicose vein yeah people
always think it's just that's what I I I
know I'm not a doctor yeah I don't I've
heard
hahaha
sorry it doesn't suck
yeah I could be Ken yeah I mean so um
I'm not a you know main guy but um what
exactly is what's going on there sorry
you've got veins going down your colon
you're like when you know when you see
like a person who has varicose veins on
the back of their legs and it's all
popped out I don't like that yeah you
don't like that well if I call it as
that going down it right but so so you
see it sometimes it pops out of this
yeah it pops out you got to push it back
up a vein no yeah half Uranus yeah you
push it back up and you just move on
with your day that's all you can do is
embarrassing sometimes they're really
itchy and sometimes they hurt a lot if
you're jamming your butthole inside your
butthole is it embarrassing well only if
you do it in front of people yeah but in
the car you're even like no no no no
[__] it's not like I I like sneeze and
then go
oh you know I need those specifics after
a [__] yeah it happens you just push it
back up and you move on yeah yeah
um but I at this very moment right now
as you're looking at me I have one with
a rubber band around it because I'm not
getting the surgery again so I've got a
very large one and there's a rubber band
around it there's a rubber band around
your [__] no they go up inside I have
a hemorrhoid that was the size of a golf
ball and they get this thing and they
put it over the top they get this rubber
band and it tightens it off like that
yeah it loses its blood flow and it
falls off strangles it strangles oh your
chokes great because if you do the
hemorroidectomy it's extremely painful
the problem is you have stitches all the
way up the colon yeah and then you have
to [__] past stitches and that's not fun
oh man [__] past stitches yes that's a
good thing how great write that down as
a band name
yeah but my point is is that don't I
just in my mind right to get a rubber
band inside your butthole yeah and to
get this triangulation thing I feel like
that's been painful no there's that
doesn't hurt at all that's embarrassing
because you have to chat to a bloke and
I haven't I haven't I have a guy and he
starts off he puts his finger up your
ass and then it prolapses out a bit you
go yeah that's been happening
and then he goes oh yeah and I said to
me he goes yeah that was a big one and I
go I go I go was it really big he goes
they don't get bigger
it hurts obviously when you have a
hemorrhoid like that yeah of course yeah
it's discomfort what does it feel like
itchy burning
like yeah and the problem with the
rubber band one then it's it pushes
against your prostate oh my God so for
like a week you feel like you have to
[__] the whole time but I'm at the last
end of it right now oh you are yeah and
then can another one arise I think I
have another three up there this is just
the biggest one we're getting rid of oh
and most people if you do like a routine
colonoscopy will have internal
hemorrhoids yeah yeah it's going to go
out and then and then they go that's why
they call them piles you ever heard the
term pile no oh that's when you've got
loads of them a pile of them
oh really y'all have pots you have a
pile of [__] yeah it's just like a
bag of grapes oh wow will I get them
eventually you probably have internal
hemorrhoids because you're 51 you should
get a colonoscopy a routine cancer yeah
yeah that's uh oh those are cute let's
suppose you have some like like they're
like pomegranates yeah yeah yeah yeah
they're bigger than pomegranates but
yeah yeah yours are but I'm saying that
they're not like they don't look like
ball sack well they can look like
externally they can pop and then just
drip blood yeah they can they bleed
bleeding's um part of them most women
when they're pregnant get one or two
yeah well they do after pregnancy from
all that pushing during labor but you
sound I feel like you have some nice
Supple poos that aren't too you drink
Metamucil at your age
um I'm only five years older
yeah but I still drink Metamucil it's
just yeah yeah yeah
I I find that um my bot inside my body
feels fine you know I mean I just my
knees how do you know
well I've had in this body over 51 years
but I've never felt the inside of my
body unless I've been sick I can't think
where my heart's feeling I know I
understand that but that's what I'm
feeling if there was an egg there then
I'd be like oh there's a problem but
nothing feels achy you do complain about
always like dripping moist stuff out of
your butt oh you get mucus yeah you get
the mucus plug yeah yeah you get the
milk sauce
is that not true you get mucus ass yeah
yeah it is but I'm not a doctor but I
would call it mucus ass I would say
mucus is a sign of inflammation I
wouldn't call it mucus maybe it's mucus
mucus ass okay it's slimy right well my
dad had it well then your dad had mucus
[__] yeah because one time he was
beating my brother
my brother woke him up from a nap and he
was playing keyboards but